okay it's the worst affected country in
the world
nearly a year after the u.s recorded its
first
covet 19 case that number has climbed to
more than 25 million
put your head back up a little bit
that's one in 14 americans
infected with the disease almost 420
000 of them have died president joe
biden says the pandemic
is his top priority but his team is
already revising his goal
of vaccinating 100 million americans in
100 days
it was a little bit of a
misunderstanding what we're talking
about is
a hundred million shots in individuals
so a shots as in other words when you
get down to let's say
a certain part of the hundred days at
the end of 100 days you're going to have
some people
who will have gotten both shots and some
will still be on their first shots what
the president is saying a hundred
million
shots in the arms of people within a
hundred days
and biden officials are accusing the
trump administration
of making a grave mistake in its
pandemic response plans
everyone american has seen the way in
which people get vaccine is chaotic it's
very
limited we've seen this factor all over
the country where
millions of doses have been distributed
about half of that has been given out
the president wants congress to approve
nearly two trillion dollars in pandemic
relief spending this on top of a
900 billion dollar measure passed back
in december
biden's fellow democrats say supporting
the economy is critical right now
but congressional republicans say not so
fast
the idea that we need a stimulus is a
little hard to understand because i i'm
one of those that's convinced that
if you want to see this economy get
going we've got to get beyond covet if
we get beyond covet i believe that the
economy is going to come
roaring back and spending and borrowing
trillions of dollars
from the chinese among others is not
necessarily the best thing we can do to
get our economy to be strong long-term
before donald trump left the white house
he lifted a covet 19 travel ban
on non-americans coming from europe and
brazil
but on monday that ban comes back and
will extend to those coming from south
africa by the end of the week
the u.s reportedly is trying to stop the
spread of the so-called
south africa variant of covet 19.
another variant from the uk has already
been found
in 20 u.s states and it said the list of
countries could get longer
if that's what it takes to end the
pandemic
rosalyn jordan al jazeera washington